hello and welcome back we'll have our
first keynote address now and we
budgeted about half an hour for Q&A at
the end and please do stay afterwards
for reception 530 until seven we're
going to be in the basement of this
building just followed the signs um
sorry it is my great pleasure and honor
to introduce our first keynote professes
to sell whiting who is currently the
Chancellor's professor in art history at
the University of California Irvine
professor Whiting's numerous
contributions to the study of the 20th
century American art are always as
innovative as their enlightening and her
work as a whole has provided a valuable
methodological and conceptual model for
many other scholars of American Art
myself included address in such very
topics as pop art post-war photography
Chicago imagism and the legacy of world
with you in post-war art on the west
coast just to name a few professor
whiting scholarship is often concerned
with the intersection of the social and
the visual focusing on historic moments
when political economical and cultural
issues emerge as contested subjects that
become FEMA ties and negotiated through
the visual production her recent book
Papalii art and the city in the 1960s
published by the University of
California Press was awarded the 21st
Charles II eldridge prize for
outstanding scholarship in the field of
American Art with a Smithsonian American
Art Museum in the study professor widen
provides an account of our denali in the
1960s that is attentive to the idea of a
place as a locus for understanding the
expanded urban landscape of post-war
America
and its effect on the visual production
her other books include a tease for
pop-pop our gender and consumer culture
published by Cambridge University Press
and anti-fascism and American art
published by Yale University Press we
the latter surveys the responses of
American artists to the rise of fascism
in Europe in the late 1930s and early
1940s by interweaving and analysis of
American visual production during the
war with the consideration of
contemporaneous political developments
and aesthetic and political theories she
exposes a network of ideas that are
central to the issue of how ideology
intersects the visual professor whiting
has recently returned to the theme of
World War two in her article California
war babies picture in World War two in
the 1960s published in our journal in
2010 focusing on the ways in which a
number of california-based artists
revisited world with you in the 1960s in
the shadow of the Vietnam War the study
prompts the questions of remembering
miss remembering and forgetting as well
as the issue of access when it comes to
the loaded historical narratives of war
violence and contested ideologies her
talk today is entitled defend in the
land reinventing the landscape please
join me in welcoming sisal whiting
thank you so much tatsiana for that
really generous introduction I'm
thrilled to be here and I want to thank
the organizers tatsiana Sophie linford
Eric striker and Tim behringer for
inviting me to participate in this
conference it's given me the chance to
revisit old work and to think about it a
new and which has been a lot of fun and
I've also really enjoyed hearing the
work today from whole new young
generation of scholars working on World
War two it's very exciting and finally I
did like looking over the rooftops from
the seventh floor garden upstairs on to
these lush green hills surrounding New
Haven is quite a contrast to my parched
Brown landscape in the irvine
during World War two photographs and
newsreels documenting death and
destruction and locales around the world
including the Naval Base of Pearl Harbor
the tropical rainforests of Guadalcanal
and the beaches of North Africa prompted
a change in painted representations of
landscape in the United States while
some American artists enlisted in the
military and documented battles abroad
others remained at home to express
sentiments related to the war and
paintings of the American land many of
these artists devised overt propaganda
developing what some critics considered
to be overheated and emotional
depictions of the American countryside
under attack or defended by heroic
farmers become valiant militiamen yet
other painters evoked the war by
registering less obvious disruptions to
the bucolic ideal while offering the
hope of imaginative regeneration of the
nation in the face of destruction
together these artists recast the terms
of landscape painting as it had been
practiced in the 1930s broadening its
scope from the local to the
international and from the pastoral to
the anti pastoral with the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor many artists who
had previously turned a blind eye to
political events in Europe and Asia took
up their paint brushes as weapons either
enlisting as war correspondence crafting
ferocious propaganda for the government
or joining nonprofit organizations such
as artists for victory for many such
artists participating directly in
wartime artistic production meant
redefining their practice by adopting
radically new subject matter on occasion
they traveled far from home Time
magazine according the director of the
Metropolitan Museum characterized the
change in blunt terms whatever his
previous preoccupation with
plums in a silver dish the artist has
now been wrenched out of it by the
danette necessity of recording the war
and here you're seeing one such artists
Aaron bull rod he wasn't actually
painting fruit and silver dishes he was
doing regionalist painting but once he
joined the army he painted in the
Pacific and then on with life magazine
he went to Europe among those artists
who stayed in the United States the
regionalist Sartre as Thomas Hart Benton
John Steuart curry and Grant Wood were
perhaps the most striking example of
artists who changed course because of
the war famous in the 1930s for being
isolationists both artistically and
politically they tried in the 1940s to
find ways to address current
international events even before the
attack on Pearl Harbor the regionalist
had begun to feel the pressure of World
War two writing in his memoirs many
years later Benton indicated that he had
become increasingly worried about the
threat of fascism before the United
States entered the conflict believing
that the war was a believing that the
country was approaching war he felt
unable to devise an appropriate artistic
response he stopped painting altogether
and departed instead on a lecture tour
Woods anxiety led him in September 1940
to try his hand at designing a
propaganda poster four bundles for
Britain a relief agency that shipped
American clothing and medical supplies
to England
produced at the beginning of the war of
the Blitz Woods poster certainly
testified to his awareness of
international events and is concerned
for the British suffering from German
air raid bombings the regionalist
Midwest was nowhere to be seen in this
poster but this did little to alter
woods reputation for isolationism critic
Peyton Boswell for instance wrote in a
review of the memorial show for wood at
the Art Institute of Chicago in 1942
quote America has been forced by fascist
enemies into an all-out war for the
democratic way of living and in that
fight most of us realize we are in a
global struggle today the United States
is perhaps more international minded
than ever before grantwood and all those
associated with him in the long crusade
for genuine native expression in the
arts are in Eclipse end quote in fact
after Pearl Harbor Benton and curry
would die two months after the attack on
Pearl Harbor so Benton and curry
attempted to produce a regionalist style
artwork focused on the Midwestern
landscape but in a manner now redolent
with international significance to say
the Benton's and curries sensibility
became international does not mean that
they abandoned their regionalist roots
nor does it imply they suddenly became
distressed about the fate of France or
England their primary concern and these
paintings remained the heartland of the
United States yet curry and Benton
recognised in these works that the
Midwest was not entirely isolated from
Europe and the Pacific it too had its
place within a global context both curry
and Benton adopted a panoramic vision to
implicate the heartland in international
events Curry's the light of the world
and I apologize for this bizarre image
but this layout appeared it as
squier magazine in December right days
before the Pearl Harbor attack and it is
literally a trifold piece of paper that
stretches out almost two feet and so
even the largest scanner in the library
does not enable me to scan the whole
thing at once and I had to do it in bits
and pieces and even here it's not in its
entire door so I apologize for that but
Curry's the light of the world appeared
in color and Esquire magazine just days
before Pearl Harbor characterized by the
magazine as quote the personification of
this moment of our world in storm and
quote the grand horizontal sweep of the
canvas splits down the middle
encompassing the local on the left and
the International on the right with
church red barn and farmhouse juxtaposed
with skyscraper and I brought in the
black and white because actually the
color image cuts cuts this off let me
see if I can operate this little
doohickey yeah it's I think more visible
here you can see the little barns and
the red houses of the little it's a red
farmhouse in the shadow of the
skyscrapers curry conflates the Midwest
with the new with new york city and has
farmers women and children huddled
together with businessmen in the harbor
watching a storm brewing across the
ocean presumably the war in Europe curry
strategy of adopting a wide-angle lens
to include the Midwest and the world
beyond it found its echo and Benton's
the year of peril apparently when Benton
heard the news about the Japanese attack
on Pearl Harbor he simply stepped off
the lecture stand in Cincinnati and went
home to Kansas City to paint a
comprehensive and blunt statement about
the war in a communication Benton
published in the press at the time he
explained quote we are fighting a war
for the preservation of
which I happen to believe in and the
artists function is to either carry guns
or bring the bloody actual realities of
this war home to the American people and
quote more specifically Benton stated
that he hoped his works would awaken the
naive isolationists of the Middle West
to the realities of war Benton painted
eight pictures which were exhibited
together the associated American artist
gallery in new york city under the title
the year of peril abbott laboratories an
international pharmaceutical firm based
in chicago published reproductions of
the eight paintings and a booklet with
an introduction by archibald macleish
then librarian of congress and head of
the office of facts and figures
newspapers around the country publicized
Benton's series and Paramount Pictures
featured it in a segment in its
newsstand for the week of April 14 1942
together the paintings developed a
narrative vividly in enumerated the gore
and violence of war the evil nature of
the fascists and in two of the paintings
the threat of fascism to a vulnerable
and sleepy Midwest three small pictures
one of which appeared on the cover of
the pamphlet produced by Abbott
Laboratories allude to the attack on
Pearl Harbor and the loss of American
lives based on mass media sources starry
night indifference and casualty depict
mangled and bloodied soldiers next to
sinking ships or destroyed planes in an
ocean setting two paintings feature the
perpetrators of destruction and
emphasize their savage nature and Benton
did resort to racist caricatures
especially in his depiction of the
Japanese in again three allegorical
figures who are identified as the
fascist powers by their Flags insignias
and military costumes thrust a spear
into the breast of
iced at the same time as he is strafed
by a Nazi plane from above it must be
the final battle since Christ lies
pinned to a cross that stands at the
edge of a cliff above a black abyss the
fascists appear as antichrists a visual
association which was standard fare in
American propaganda at the time for many
Americans the war formed a clear-cut
battle between democracy and fascism
barbarism and civilization pagan ignem
and Christianity in sewers the fascists
assume the guise of bulky monsters
outlined against a blackened sky they
tread across a desolate landscape swept
by fire and toss human skulls from
bulging bags onto the ground the loss of
an agrarian ideal is made most explicit
and sewers but in fact dark skies
apocalyptic fires and parched landscapes
set the stage for all the paintings in
the series and all the actions
testifying to fascist infamy take place
in this sort of setting having depicted
the casualties and suffering of soldiers
and sailors and having named the enemy
Benton literally brought the war home in
two paintings harvest and invasion give
form to Benton's nightmarish vision of
what the fascists might do to mainland
America and to the Midwest in particular
if they were to invade no longer did
Benton offer an optimistic view of the
Middle West with lush rolling hills
peopled by yeoman farmers instead he
populated this once-peaceful region with
horrible fascist monsters murdered
Midwesterners and a devastated landscape
harvest presents a rural scene with
cornfields inflamed the farm buildings
and home reduced to rubble the father
and child dead and the mother screaming
in fear harvest forecasts what Benton
must have conceived as the worst
possible loss to the indifferent
farmer a similar scene of devastation
occurs in the second largest canvas in
the series entitled invasion in this
painting the fascist enemy trespasses
across the great slice of the country
from shining sea to amber waves of grain
Benton uses a wide-angle lens
perspective reminiscent of Curry's the
light of the world to capture a sweeping
view of the United States he combines
the eastern seaboard and the Midwest the
city in the country Benton replaces
Curry's impending storm with actual
ships arriving from Europe on the right
the invaders make their way through the
city it is New York before we see the
Empire State Building and out across the
countryside with their tanks there among
haystacks farms and green hills dark
skinned and Simeon looking soldiers
attack a rural family whiskey bottles in
hand they destroy the land rape a woman
mutilate children and ram a bayonet
through the throat of a farmer in this
picture the war has moved from across
the ocean in Europe and escalated into a
full-scale invasion of the heartland the
fascist attack convulses the Midwestern
landscape like the tornado in The Wizard
of Oz that sweeps up Dorothy's farmhouse
from its flat Kansas plane the
foreground in Benton's canvas literally
tips up catapulting all the figures
across it in a diagonal Benton combines
the regional and the International in a
stretch from background depth to
foreground climax where the agrarian
ideal is upended literally and
figuratively I dwell on Benton series at
some length to point out one obvious
example of an artist who rethought
landscape painting in the aftermath of
Pearl Harbor emphasizing Americans
America's vulnerability by turning the
Midwest into an imaginary battlefront
Benton's series exemplified some of the
key strategies of
early wartime propaganda narrative
messages meant to generate strong
emotions to be channeled into the war
effort the imagined desecration of land
played a central role in each painting
in Benton's narrative and culminated in
the violent destruction of the heartland
even in exterminate Benton's final and
largest painting in the year of peril
series in which he offers a glimmer of
hope by depicting the American military
defeating the fascist monsters the
farmer and his child they could have
been plucked from harvest or invasion by
pale skeletal and drained of life the
landscape is dark with belching smoke in
the background and skills and dead
bodies litter the foreground in contrast
curry transformed his Midwestern farmers
into intrepid soldiers standing in
abundant Wisconsin wheat fields or by
bucolic farms defending the American
agricultural ideal in painting
subsequently turned into posters for the
United States Treasury our good earth
keep it ours was reproduced in the print
media and made into a colorful poster
brandishing the red white and blue of
the American flag
the painting features a muscular farmer
standing erect flanked by children and
surrounded by bountiful golden wheat
waving in the breeze while grasping
three stalks of wheat and his hand the
farmer stares off to the distance
defiantly as if daring an enemy attack
wartime posters often called farmers to
join soldiers and doing their part and
defending our Good Earth here pictured
narrowly as the Midwestern wheat fields
by maintaining agricultural production
to feed citizens at home and abroad the
farm is a battlefield to painted
originally for the Wisconsin State Fair
in august of 1942 makes this alliance
much more explicit with its farmers
standing shoulder-to-shoulder with
soldiers the farmers pitchfork points
backwards to a second farmer perched on
his tractor and plowing the land beyond
him is a little red farm nestled among
the patchwork of cultivated fields in
the meantime the first farmer marches
forward into battle with two infantrymen
aiming their weapons forward standing in
formation they have just stepped down an
incline and together with a tank they
establish a barrier between the dark
shadowy ground before them and the
peaceful agrarian landscape behind in
both posters the combination of
bountiful landscape and heroic farmers
play on emotions of pride and land and
region to generate commitment to a
nation's mission at war over propaganda
of the sort seen in Benton's and curries
pictures meant to stimulate the American
public's dedication to the war effort
found a sympathetic audience among
interventionists many of whom had been
worried about the lack of American
patriotism since the fall of France in
1940 at the same time as the
interventionists had first begun
alerting Americans to the problem of
public morale pres
Roosevelt had begun seeking approval for
support of endangered England Roosevelt
and the interventionists hoped to gain
the American public's endorsement for a
policy that would assure a British
victory over Nazi Germany even after
Pearl Harbor Roosevelt and his
administration believed that the public
was still not entirely willing to
support a war abroad much less fight it
at first they feared that military
setbacks would contribute to diminishing
American commitment to fighting the war
later starting in 1943 they worried that
publicizing only victories would distort
the expectations and perceptions of the
American public as George roeder argues
in the censored war advisers to
Roosevelt proposed that the government
released harsher photographs emphasizing
the realities of war to prepare the
public for greater casualties this
policy soon became public as rotor
points out when in may of 1943 newsweek
grand photographs of americans badly
injured in the pacific campaign and
announced that quote to harden Homefront
morale the military service have adopted
a new policy of letting civilians see
photographically what warfare does to
men who fight Life magazine probably the
most widely read photo magazine of the
day released its first photograph of
Americans killed in the war in September
of 1943 showing three American soldiers
lying dead on buna beach in New Guinea
beginning in 1943 then magazines
newspapers and news reels were suddenly
filled with photographs driving home the
terrible toll of the war although many
adopted a distanced view either
panoramic or aerial some began to close
in on landscapes of death and
destruction bodies of dead American
soldiers sprawled on the ground
dead remains of the enemy and blasted
buildings themselves characterized as
skeletons and cadavers captions vividly
described the experience of being in a
landscape transformed into a war zone
the stench of dead bodies the blinding
smoke the heat of fire the drone of
aircraft approaching to bomb and the
deafening explosion of artillery and
bombs the landscape had become a booby
trap even a close-up of seemingly
innocuous trees perched in a meadow
could contain threatening details of
abandoned line landmines and hastily
prepared graves a caption in Life
Magazine below a photograph of Japanese
casualties acknowledged the loss of an
idyllic landscape transformed by death
and destruction and the caption reads in
part quote in peaceful times a pleasant
little beach ran along the New Guinea
shore the waves lapped gently on the
sand and then the caption goes on to
describe Japanese soldiers who had
rushed into the from their positions
into the ocean into the water into the
sea and it goes on to say most of the
bodies rolled back eventually to the
beach where maggots devoured them
overall hung the stench of death end
quote together photographs and texts
brought home the realities of the war
with graphic descriptions of ruined
noxious and dangerous landscapes
conscripted painters were also given
license to testify to the horrors of
being on the battlefront their
landscapes often sought to give some
meaning to the realities that they
witnessed and again I apologize for this
horrible image because it's obviously
taken from a book and it's the only
color image I could find if George
Biddle's painting death at Rowley in
which a seated soldier gazes pensively
upon a dead enemy two dead mules and a
blasted tree limb even as the Allies
have apparently achieved a victory the
disorder of the foreground contrast to
the conventions of a claudian
compositional order in the background
where two trees frame of you onto a
valley apparently unbesmirched by the
ravages of war a difference between
peaceful backdrop and war-ravaged
foreground between life and death order
and disorder can't help but raise
questions about the toll of the war
laying the moral blame for the loss of
life and the loss of a bucolic landscape
squarely on the enemy still life
Guadalcanal by Aaron Burr odd offers a
reflection of mortality by combining gas
masks skull and human bones identified
as Japanese by a caption accompanied the
reproduction of this painting and Life
magazine as well as bullet-riddled
helmets which life labeled as American
helmets these material remains lie
scattered among the limbs roots and
rotting leaves of a tree and next to the
opening of a bunker the detritus from
both the American and Japanese sides of
the war collected in this scene would
seem to suggest equality and death ball
rod and biddle both present traces of a
battle that has presumably already taken
place transforming the pastoral
landscape into a memorial in which
bodies skulls and the decay and chaos of
nature attests to the loss of land as a
safe and peaceful sanctuary after 1943 a
number of American artists at home who
resisted the pressure to produce
propaganda or images explicitly about
the war nevertheless registered the
impact of seeing photographs and
paintings of wartime death and
destruction a striking number of artists
even Thomas Hart Benton align themselves
with surreal
during the war and began to depict a
traumatized landscape closing in on
deteriorating vegetation and decaying
bodies bones and skulls there's as an
agonized wounded landscape haunted by
photographs and paintings from the war
this vision at its most bleak is
exemplified by Frederic summer a
photographer working in Arizona gory war
photographs of dead soldiers could not
have helped but hot summer and his
photographs provided some of the most
disturbing displacements of death on to
the American landscape produced during
the war pointing his camera down rather
than a cross to distant mountains he
zoomed in on dead and decaying animals
embedded in the ground in this example
from 1945 the impossibly thin legs of a
horse stretch horizontally across the
terrain while it's decomposing body lies
partially buried in the dirt and leaves
summer began aiming his camera's
viewfinder on animal skeletons as early
as 1939 when he photographed a
jackrabbit and in 1941 he shot his first
image of dead coyotes in 1945 he
produced a series of focusing on
decomposing animal bodies especially
horses and coyotes in coyotes of 1945
summer looks straight down on four
skinned animals arrayed on parched soil
the corpses extend beyond the frame as
if to suggest that we are seeing but a
fragment of a larger landscape littered
with even more dead bodies from this
proximate perspective we are forced to
consider the brute reality of death the
bones covered with dried tissue Tufts of
fur remaining at Taylor paw sharp
canines and incisors empty eye sockets
that summer's photographs troubled
viewers is clear from contempt
comments in a letter to summer nancy
newhall acting curator of photography at
MoMA between 1942 and 1945 expressed
dismay with the photographers quote
preoccupation with the themes of death
and disintegration end quote summer
intern reacted in a manner that reveals
how memories of the war lingered over
the slaughter he brought into view
saying how could anybody think that
anything I could do with a camera could
in any way annoy anybody's finer
feelings when they were giving consent
to warfare on a scale unprecedented more
palatable perhaps were those landscapes
that combine the material remains of
death with evidence of renewal even
summer produced such photographs for
instance he eliminated the horizon line
in his photograph bloody basin of 1943
and concentrates on the hardscrabble
arizona landscape the spot was named to
commemorate conflicts between the
american military and the Apaches the
culminated in an ambush in 1873 in which
26 Indians jumped off the cliff to their
death but it was just the sort of label
that would have been used to character
rise fields of battle during World War
two the photograph does not provide a
prospect in the foreground from which to
view a peaceful Vista or an
awe-inspiring mountain as might even a
conventional tourist photograph of this
area nor does it contain skeletal
remains or blood testifying to warfare
neither sublime nor grotesque the
photograph shot some 60 years after the
Apache defeat simply highlights the
desert vegetation which continues to
grow over the rocky terrain in spite of
previous warfare only the title evokes
the memory of bloody human death just a
summer found a landscape redolent with
memories of war
so to Benton following the end of
hostilities depicted mementos of death
embedded in a resurgent American
Farmland in after many Springs of 1945 a
skull and a revolver nestled between a
dead tree limb and a moss-covered rock
in the foreground while the farmer tills
the land in the background although the
six-shooter revolver marks the erstwhile
owner of the weapon a casualty of
distant frontier days the inclusion of
the skull suggests that even the
innocent Heartland is far from pristine
the skull in the landscape is inevitably
evokes the beach and battle scenes from
the war and even as the background
promises renewal the parallels between
the furrows and the farmland and the
riffles in the dead tree limb suggests
that middle America has lost its
innocence unable to rid its fertile
fields of the inevitable tincture of
death the farmer may turn his back on
the skull may not even be aware of it
but we as viewers must take in both
death and life blooms the rock a
painting that preoccupied the artist for
the duration of the war though he did
not complete it until 1948 also combines
evidence of death and destruction
alongside signs of renewal in the center
a blasted rock moss-covered on the
outside bloody red and fissured on the
inside sits on a brown slab its self
resting on a natural pedestal of dirt
and slabs of stone an animal skeleton
and flowering stump lie before the rock
and a young girl kneels before it with
her arms upraised grasping the dirt and
a root is the rock a miniature version
of the earth blasted apart by the war or
is it the agent of destruction a meteor
fallen to earth a kind of naturalistic
atom bomb does the girl worship a false
calf or does she raised her arms and
bear about the fate of the earth all of
the other figures in the scene are busy
ignoring the rock and the girl and
instead working together either to clear
up the debris beneath the rock and at
the site of a ruined red building or to
construct a new building perhaps frank
lloyd wright's fallingwater with its
distinctive brick chimney and this was
the come up painting that was
commissioned by Edgar Kaufmann the owner
of falling water earlier Austin
explained that Blum was very traumatized
because he couldn't find a solution to
this painting and he eventually
completed this work the skeletal remains
of the red brick building at right
resembled the ruins depicted on the
sheaf of paper held by one of the
patients in fracture ward of 1944 ruins
bloom claimed or inspired by photographs
of the London after the Blitz that
building and the central rock would seem
to be direct references to the time of
World War two yet the workers seem to
belong to a moment beyond the chaos of
war as their bodies create a narrative
arc of renewal from the ruins in the
right background looping around the
blasted rocket center and connecting
back to the construction site to the
left and I'm sure you can so pick it's
hard to see from this angle
here here going all the way around our
critics agreed that the rock balanced
recognition of wars destructive power
with hope one wrote for instance quote
the painting symbolizes according to the
artist the continued process of man's
rebuilding out of a devastated world one
account has it that the shattered blood
red rock represents the world today
surrounded by symbols of destruction
skeletons blasted trees burning debris
and the crumbling edifices of man but at
the same time there is a note of hope in
Bloom's world where life blooms even in
the midst of decay a scarlet fungus
grows full bloom out of a dead and
rotten stump people feverishly got
grovel in the ruins building for
themselves a new and better world
perhaps the most optimistic paintings to
celebrate renewal in the face of death
are Georgia O'Keeffe's paintings begun
in 1943 and completed in 1945 depicting
pelvis bones in the New Mexico desert
hope does not reside in the tilling of
the land the literal growth of
vegetation or the reconstruction of
buildings but in the timelessness of the
sky as she made clear in a statement
issued when she first exhibited the
paintings at Stieglitz is gal arree an
american place in 1944 numerous critics
quoted O'Keeffe when they reviewed the
show and I'll just quote you quote the
ending statement or the ending sentences
of her statement that's in the brochure
that accompanied the exhibition quote
when I started painting the pelvis bones
I was most interested in the holes and
the bones what I saw through them
particularly the blue from holding them
in the Sun against the sky as one is apt
to do when one seems to have more sky
than earth in one's world they were the
most wonderful
against the blue that blue that will
always be there as it is now after all
man's destruction is finished and quote
and critics repeatedly quoted that last
sentence and understood these as making
some sort of statement about the
destruction of the war O'Keefe's letters
from the war also invite us to think
about these paintings in relation to
world events the war was already on
O'Keefe's mind in the fall of nineteen
thirty nine when she wrote artist and
educator russell vernon hunter to tell
him that Stieglitz was not well having
suffered heart-attack she concluded
quote the war had upset him very much as
if to suggest that the war was
responsible for Stieglitz asst heart
attack in that same letter she admitted
that were not for the war and all the
uncertainties have brought she would
have made another trip to the tropics
she had traveled to Hawaii in 1937 a
trip funded by the dole pineapple
company we know as well from O'Keefe's
letters that while her house at ghost
ranch and that that's a house that was
on a huge property near abiquiu might
have been remote from New York City it
was not far from wartime activity the
main house that the compound became a
weekend retreat for some of the men who
worked at nearby Los Alamos even though
it was highly unlikely that she knew
what they were up to at that famously
secretive atomic site she must have
caught hints that something related to
the government to science to the war
preoccupied these men in any case as the
war escalated O'Keefe had to deal with
racials and even though she did not have
a radio she did read Time magazine which
was filled with news about the war
preparation for war aftermath of battles
lots of articles about war art
preoccupied by her by war and her worry
about Stieglitz who had become
increasingly frail during this time she
found a glimmer of hope in the sky the
sky beyond human temporality of war and
destruction emptied of airplanes and
bombers provided O'Keefe with
of eternity and this struck me
particularly yesterday the group of
speakers met together in the study room
of the Yale art gallery we're looking at
various pictures including some
watercolors by Peter Hurd an American
artist who did some fascinating images
from the window of an airplane and so
you see the mechanical frame of the
airplane window and you see the sky and
the clouds beyond but you're also
looking through the tail gunner's
gunsight so it's very explicitly about
that aerial that the aerial vision on to
the sky being a militarized vision and
this isn't strong contrast of course to
what he was doing that pure vision of
sky takes form in the last paintings in
the pelvis series when she turned her
back on the landscape of New Mexico
which she had painted over and again
since her first trip to the state in
1929 even the early examples in the
pelvis series while perhaps her most
unconventional landscapes to date did
preserve thin black shadowy outlines of
the mesas even while concentrating on
massive polished bones swooping through
the terrain however in pull this one and
pelvis 3 both of 1944 the landscapes
simply disappeared crevices in the
whitewashed bones served as peep holes
through which we see blue presumably the
sky with some wisps of white cloud
staring at the blue sky celebrating the
heavens as beyond human destructiveness
is certainly hopeful as O'Keefe depicted
blue framed by the holes in the pelvic
bone she offered an escape for the
imagination to the other side of deaths
remains into open empty space her
embrace of the sky enabled her to
reinvent her practice of landscape
painting after world war two the more
conventional or picturesque vistas on
two mesas and beauty
that she had painted even as late as
1941 are a rare exception and here i
show you one of her last kind of views
vistas that she did of the buttes she
began by abandoning naturalistic colors
in the works from 1944 as we see in
goat's horn with red and pelvis red and
yellow both of 1945 bright loops of
orange red only vaguely relating to the
contours of bone or horn circle areas of
color unnatural and their purity and
intensity blue in one case yellow and
the other as the artists increasingly
simplified the landscape she collapsed
figure and ground foreground and
background creating abstracted terrains
and rivers seen from the air as in it
was red and pink of 1959 and she does
start to fly in airplanes and depict the
river the landscape from above seeking
an alternative to man's destruction to
her anxious times oki free
conceptualized the land by looking
through the bones at the sky eventually
she would adopt an aerial vision looking
down from airplanes onto the land in
1945 with the news about the liberation
of the concentration camps and the
destruction of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
the euphoria about the end of the war
was tempered with the recognition of the
human capacity for evil and destruction
in retrospect we may think that the hope
that some of these artists invested in
reconstruction nature and even the
imagination was misplaced and somewhat
naive in the moment however several
artists such as bloom and Benton
countered the destruction of war by
developing narratives of renewal over
time in which reconstruction in the
present nevertheless always recognized
the destructiveness of the past O'Keefe
offered yet another possibility
countering change over time with the
eternal present in which one
away from the past forgets death and
destruction and does not focus on the
future but instead achieves a blinding
moment of transcendence thank you